unanimidad entre los 27 para salvar la
campaña de turismo del próximo verano
para lograrlo los estados de la unión
europea coincidieron en la necesidad de
que la población cuente con un
certificado inmunitario
si en alemania decidimos desarrollar un
certificado de vacuna nacional de este
tipo los datos básicos que debe contener
dicho certificado están definidos por la
comisión europea y los estados miembros
sin embargo se necesitarán tres meses de
trabajo técnico para establecer cómo
será el documento y para conocer si
finalmente las personas vacunadas
transmiten el virus pese a no
desarrollar la enfermedad
la idea es que el certificado entré en
vigor en verano una implementación que
despierta dudas en francia el presidente
manuel macrón pidió sentido común en los
requisitos para los certificados de
vacunas no soy un cultivo podemos
condicionar su acceso así a alguien ha
sido vacunado o no cuando ni siquiera
habríamos abierto la campaña de
vacunación a los más jóvenes en la
reunión los líderes también acordaron
mantener estrictas restricciones antes
del verano prevenir nuevas variantes y
avanzar en la vacunación pese a los
retrasos ursula von der leyen presidenta
de la comisión europea aseguró que a
finales de verano se habrá vacunado al
70% de la población
son 255 millones de personas vacunadas
en la unión europea y si miramos las
cifras previstas es un objetivo que
aseguró conseguir
go that's with conference which los
líderes comunitarios aprovecharon la
reunión para enviar un mensaje de unidad
tras las críticas recibidas se ha
cuestionado el retraso en la campaña de
inoculación respecto a israel reino
unido- y estado